[Music]
i'm beryl
joined by my puppy asha hello
and this week we're looking at eggs
there are a lot of ways to cook an egg
and that's because
they're versatile egg dishes can be
found on
every corner of this planet so when i
made this episode
i decided to give myself one hard rule
to follow
no chicken egg dishes so things get a
little funky in this episode
i like it i hope you guys do too i spoke
to seven people
in seven countries to see different eggs
and their dishes
around the world so this is the egg
episode
in making this episode i decided two
things
number one i wanted to find as many
different
eggs as possible and number two like i
said before
no chicken eggs so with that in mind
let's get cracking
i rubbed that one
the dish is a traditional south african
ostrich egg
which is set in a pan fried up with
ingredients like budovers
onions and eggs escamoles
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
we're going to start with the largest
egg of the bunch an ostrich egg
from a breakfast dish in south africa
the ostrich egg is obviously special to
the country
it's the egg of the biggest bird in the
world and the egg weighs in at about 1.5
kilograms which is the equivalent to
24 to 27 chicken eggs
my name is peter de jacob and i'm from
stellenbosch
we are making an ostrich egg crustless
quiche it's a typical dish in south
africa especially for breakfast
my mother-in-law actually taught me how
to make this dish she grew up on a farm
that had a lot of ostriches
we get these eggs from any of the
ostrich ranchers here in south africa
to crack the egg i usually use a
serrated knife
to run it around the tip of the egg
and then you use either the heel of a
knife or a cleaver
and you just chop all the way around the
egg
until that weakened piece
comes straight off and loosens itself
from the shell and then you pierce
through the little film
on the inside
then you add the beaten egg into the pan
you turn down the heat to a low and you
leave
the egg to simmer in the pan
and then once it's litified you take it
out of the pan
you cut it up into wedges and then you
serve it with
a green herb salsa
the egg tastes a little bit eggier
it almost tastes as what an egg smells
like it's got a
more venison game like flavor but still
very much egg i like eating these eggs
because number one it feeds a lot of
people
and number two it's got a wonderful rich
flavor
next up let's go with the smallest snail
eggs
it's a thing
on france
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
exclusively
[Music]
[Music]
moving from land to sea in japan octopus
eggs
are hard to find delicacy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for a midday break duck eggs are an
important part of this tea
in indonesia
[Music]
foreign
in sri lanka they're cooking up fish
eggs but not the type of caviar you
might expect
[Music]
in
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
known as mexican caviar these eggs come
from small insects ants
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
and lastly it's a repeat egg the duck
but a completely different presentation
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this episode was a little bit different
from episodes past where usually i try
to find a through line
and in this one i tried to differentiate
them all
but i think that the thesis of the
series still holds up
we saw all of this wonderful variance
around this one word
the egg and i know that some of the
dishes might have been
a little bit out there but the point of
this series is to open our minds and
explore the world through food because
food can be
a lot of things and eggs can be a lot
more than just the typical chicken egg
we eat this dish on special occasions
especially when we have a lot of friends
around or you have to cook breakfast for
many people it's a wonderful egg to feed
a lot of people
[Music]
it is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
francis